[Applause]
the aftermath of what initially appeared
to be a car accident at Egypt's
government now beliefs was far more
sinister I was shocked and all cars
behind me were on fire all the people at
the back died do not let anyone tell you
anything else everyone died mostly they
were children a speeding car collided
with other vehicles outside a cancer
hospital in Cairo the interior ministry
says there were explosives in the car
that were to be used in a terrorist
operation there was a sound of an
extremely loud blast it was no way to
cars crashing the car must have been
rigged with explosives it was to the
extent where on the other side the
apartments were shaking they were taking
people out and the other people were
melted together it was a strange
situation dozens of people were killed
or injured and patients being treated at
the cancer hospital had to be
transferred because of damage to the
building perhaps of the ceiling of the
hospital we're collapsing and I went out
of the room and people were running
everywhere and shouting and people were
collapsing
President Abdel Fattah el-sisi tweeted
his condolences to the victims adding
that his government is determined to
confront and eradicate what he calls
brutal terrorism his forces are already
battling armed groups in the Sinai
Peninsula and have been several attacks
against civilians in Egyptian cities in
recent years last month British Airways
temporarily suspended flight to Cairo
citing security concerns the government
doesn't seem to believe that the
hospital was the target it was more an
issue of the explosive material wasn't
properly secured and was detonated
prematurely but it is of concern of
course that this much explosive material
is brought into the center of Cairo and
the scale of the explosion the blast
area the fact that there are reports
that bodies were projected even into the
Nile suggests that it was a quite a
substantial amount of explosives Egypt's
Prosecutor General's ordered an
investigation into what happened on
Sunday night but for now this Cairo
Street has become a crime scene
alexia al Jazeera